hey everyone I'm Priyanka Vergara and
you are watching deconstructing chatbots
in today's episode we will explore
entities further from the second and
third episodes you might remember that
entities are dialogue flows mechanism
for identifying and extracting useful
data from users input if you've not
checked out the episode on getting
started with dialogue flow please do so
for more context just roll up to the
second episode on the right or click in
the link in description below there are
three types of entities system entities
developer entities and session entities
now you might remember from our
appointment scheduler chatbot when we
said need an appointment for 4 p.m.
tomorrow the date and time were
automatically extracted a system
entities date and time it was all
automatic as you saw system entities
allow agents to extract information
about the wide range of concepts without
any additional configuration data like
address emails currency phone numbers
are some of the common examples of
system entities now so far we have been
addressing our appointment scheduler in
a generic manner let's say our scheduler
is for DMV we click on entities and
create a new entity let's call this
appointment type let's think about the
types of services DMV offers most people
go to DMV for a driver's license
maybe vehicle registration also driving
tests so in our scenario let's stick to
the two main services driver's license
and micro registration are obviously the
two main ones that I can think of that
DME offers so let's create those two as
entities you can add more rows with more
services as entity types additionally
you can check the box to add more
entities automatically when an entity is
not available in the entity list dialog
flow identifies that this is an entity
based on
they're training phrases and adds that
new entity automatically to the list you
can also upload or download entities in
bulk in CSV or JSON format now let's add
more intense to accommodate the
appointment type entity in our inputs
when you add set an appointment for
driver's license for 3:00 p.m. tomorrow
driver's license has identified as
developer entity that we just set up
while time and date are obviously system
entities add a few more training phrases
like these now remember slot filling
from episode 3 when we built our
appointment scheduler to book an
accurate appointment we needed to make
appointment type a required field just
like time and date let's define the
write prompt for when a user does not
provide us the appointment type now
while we are at it let's modify our
response to include the appointment type
along with the date and time to make it
look more complete when done don't
forget to save your changes and then
let's just our updates now with some
sample inputs the first example let's
say user only gives us the appointment
type well it's not filling kicks in and
asks for the time and the date when they
want to come in all looks good we get
the appointment scheduled in the second
example let's say a user says I need an
appointment for 4 p.m. tomorrow without
providing us the appointment type again
our slot filling kicks in and prompts
the user to provide us the service
information they say driver's license
and we provide them a response with
their appointment confirmation in our
third and last example let's say the
user gave us all three things we needed
in just one shot set an appointment for
Waker registration at 2:00 p.m. tomorrow
our bot has everything it needs so it
sends a confirmation response back to
the user right away now the turn type of
entity is session entity these are
defined at session ID level which allows
for a specific entity to be tied to a
user and there
session let's take an example to
understand this better our agent had
appointment type as entity which
includes driver's license and vehicle
registration at this point that entity
could be updated to include a state ID
or a motorcycle test depending on the
information your agent collects from the
user during the conversation the updated
session entity will have state ID or
motorcycle test entry for rest of the
conversation with your user well try
this out on your own and let me know how
it goes in the comments below remember
you will create manage and update
session entities using the API alright
that was a lot so let's summarize today
we looked at the three types of entities
system entity developer entity and
session entities then we went hands-on
and learnt how to set up these entities
in our appointment scheduler chatbot
don't miss the next episode of
deconstructing chatbots because we are
going to integrate our appointment
scheduler with Twilio messaging service
[Music]